brianne
is with us in kansas is it brienne is
that correct
it is brienne thank you sure how can i
help
well thanks for taking my call the um
reason i'm calling today is i own
three small businesses they are all
located in an
eighteen thousand square foot facility
here in kansas city
and um to say the least
kovan has hit us painfully painfully
hard
and um i can see that it affects me
mentally physically
everything and i'm trying to
i've had to let go 50 percent of my
staff we're running on bones right now
just trying to keep the doors open we
got terrible news from our
landlords this past week and there's a
lot of unknowns so we just
i just need to know what should i do
to help my employees through this time
help them
that i can tell they have so much fear
and i just want to see how
i know i'm affecting them how can i help
them what should i what should i say to
them
should i be honest with them about
everything should i i feel like i should
but
maybe i shouldn't i don't know
they often tell us on the airplane um
when you got small
kids that you got to make sure you put
your oxygen mask on first
before you start taking care of them and
so you made a couple of statements here
i want to make sure
that you are taking care of you in these
moments and then i'd like to refer back
to
dave if that's okay how i've seen as a
new employee to the ramsey family
um dave and his executive team get up
every monday morning on his on a call
to the entire all thousand of us and
gives us a real transparent yet hopeful
yet honest view of what's going on and
here's the plan for today and for this
week and what it looks like so
i'm going to recommend to you that you
got to make a plan for every day you've
got to default to the things that keep
you well and keep you whole
for me that's making sure i get out and
move and i eat right and
i'm connecting with people outside of my
work that know me that i have a
relationship with
um and that i'm connecting with the
people inside my house
this thing will eat you alive especially
you start having to do hard things like
lay people off
and then you've got to focus on those
few things you can control which
unfortunately for a lot of us
are way fewer than we thought right um
and dave
i'll let you lead your company as far as
the
folks on your team they can handle bad
news
better than they can handle no news
and uh i wouldn't add drama your job is
to remove drama
but tell the truth and um you know we've
shared with our team even some of our
internal accounting numbers
this is how much cash we have this is
how much payroll costs
and when revenue turns down here's the
first things we will do
uh if revenue doesn't turn back up in
time here's the second things we will do
if the revenue doesn't turn back up in
time here's the third thing we will do
and here's what's going to happen and so
in your case what i would say is is this
business is affected this way
this business you got two three
businesses they're probably different
situations on revenue
and just look at those particular team
members and go guys here's what's
happening show them the chart uh you can
show them you know here
and and i you know i i love you guys and
i want to keep you
i wouldn't have hired you if i didn't
want you here and um
and so i'm going to do everything i can
to for us to
all survive this together but even if we
don't you're going to hear the truth
from me and you're going to hear it
early and you're going to hear often
and i told our team four weeks ago uh
i said one thing you won't be is
surprised
you're gonna know what's happening and
i'm gonna we are gonna make
calm wise deliberate
decisions ahead of time and then we're
gonna walk right down those flowcharted
decisions
unless something affects one of those
flow charts that's exactly what we're
going to do what we decided in the
moment
before the emergency comes on the
training kicks in
when the plan kicks in when the
emergency comes and so
you know here's what's happening our
landlord we got bad news from them on
this
we got this revenue stream here as you
know we've already laid off this group
um here's what we're going to do next um
i'm not taking pay
here's what we're going to do then you
know you can just share with them
you know exactly what's going on but
don't add drama to it and don't go away
you know if
president trump doesn't get us back to
work by may second it's all over
you know you got because even though
that might be playing in your
brain that's the adding drama you just
john says when he used to do a lot of
crisis work when you're in crisis facts
are your friends just tell people what
the facts are and tell yourself what the
facts are
over and over and over and over again
we're sending out a newsletter every
morning because our team's working from
home updating them
on the number of uh tests that have been
done for covid
the number of cases and the number of by
the way the ones that had
covet are all healed just as a good news
for ramsey people but
um uh you know and we're updating
everybody on what's going on because
they were scared of their brains on some
of this stuff
and and um you know just take the drama
out take the drama out
tell people the truth even if it's bad
news because if you don't tell them
what's going on they're going to in
their brain make it a whole lot worse
than it is
in the absence of data we make up
stories right and they're going to
invent and then they're going to attach
morality to it they're going to make you
the bad person
instead of just the message bearer yeah
especially if there are certain
personality types
they they there are certain personality
types that there has to be
a villain there has to be a right and a
wrong and if
i'm right then you have to you have to
be wrong because i can't write my story
otherwise
and that's that's an immature person but
there are personality types that lend
themselves to that more often than not
and they have to write out a narrative
for instance we've had people that used
to work here
and it's it's such a wonderful place to
work if you don't work here anymore
because you quit
you've got to have a villain right you
got to have you got a negative narrative
well you can't it has to be negative you
can't just go
well they're good and i'm good you have
to go oh they must suck
because i'm not there they must not
really be they must be a bunch of
hypocrites
because i'm not there anymore and you
have to make up crap and rewrite a
narrative in your head instead of just
going you know what they're not perfect
i'm not perfect and we didn't see eye to
eye and i split the place there you go
and i think it's critical to remember
that
kids are this way in your house your
employees are this way
when you're stressed and you are tense
people feel it on you well they know it
you can smell it
and so if you're not being transparent
then not only are you not
helping them but now they think you're
not telling the truth right i mean i
even did a lesson
in staff meeting on how we how we handle
stress
and i told everybody here's how i handle
it i get pissed off right and here's how
you handle it some of you you get
freaked out
i eat gummy candy pathologically yeah
but i mean you know we just said you
know i told them
you remember me teaching you you're
either going to process this fear you're
compressed
as anger and they're very very similar
emotions and i
did a lesson on it you know from from a
leadership position to tell him
and i told him look if if you're going
on how i'm going to react i'm going to
go and tell you i'm a hillbilly i'm
going to be pissed off about whatever it
is
that's my default i'm going to start
there and probably in there
you know but when in doubt hit something
you know and um
that's not necessarily right but being
afraid is not necessarily right but i
went ahead and told them
what to expect from their leader you
know their imperfect
leader that this is what's this is how
i'm going to react to these things i'm
going to try to do
be wise in the middle of it but if you
see me just really angry that just means
i'm stressed
if you see me really passionate pissed
off about you know the president or the
governor or whatever it's it's
it has nothing to do with anything it's
just how i process this stuff the first
thing i do is i
have to hit it in the mouth and then we
figure it out from there and
some people go the other way they go the
fear away and neither one's right
neither one's wrong it's just the way
people process it i did a lesson on it i
helped everybody understand
oh yeah that is kind of me and i see how
dave does that and i don't that's why i
don't understand him because i'm not
like him you know and
as an employee that was a gift because
now i know now i know right i've got the
information that we need
and then i can go about my job yeah it's
uh
i don't have to i don't have to concoct
some wild story about why dave's mad and
why
i don't have to i haven't seen you mad
at me so well i wasn't mad at anybody
i'm just pissed about the whole thing
that's right
just in general i just i don't like
fighting something i can't see
oh man the unseen ah that's driving me
crazy
so hey brian's really good question
thanks for letting us talk it through
with you
and you're a better leader than you
probably think you are just because you
knew to ask the question you're
self-aware
calm is contagious be honest there you
go big
time so sphere this is the dave ramsey
show